dans une tribune libre publiée par le
journal Le Monde une soixantaine de
cinéastes appellent les Français à
désobéir aux lois sur l'immigration et
plus précisément à l'obligation qui
pourrait être faite au particulier de
déclarer l'arrivée ou le départ d'un
étranger chez eux cet appel à la
désobéissance civile a été qualifiée
d'inadmissible par Jacques Toubon alors
que la socialiste Martine auri se
réjouissait au contraire je cite devoir
des intellectuel s'opposer à une loi
iniique le point de la polémique Olivier
carof ce cé d'arrêtdcè parisien s'est
transformé pour quelques heures en
temple de la contestation des lois sur
l'immigration une cinquantaine de jeunes
réalisateurs ont officiellement demander
leur mise en examen pour avoir hébergé
des étrangers en situation irrégulière
il y a une semaine un tribunal avait
retenu ce motif pour condamner une jeune
femme pourquoi ça tombe sur elle parce
que la loi est naz tout le monde le sait
tous les jurist savent qu'elle est naze
auxilire de police à vérifier les PAP
des gens qui V chez soi notre métier
c'est de dire aux gens ouvrer les yeux
notre métier c'est de d'ouvrir les yeux
sur des choses et de faire réagir les
gens et chacun réagit à sa façon et
certains de leurs aînés n'ont pas tardé
à réagir comme Claude Miller ou Bertrand
Tavernier très bien quand ils me l'ont
envoyé j'ai je me suis dit que je devais
vieillir parce que j'aurais adoré avoir
cette idée je trouve que c'est une idée
magnifique que de dire quand une loi est
crapuleuse nous désobéissons à cette loi
je n'ai pas fait cette loi principale
cible le projet de loi de Jean-Louis
Debray récemment discuté au Sénat il
doit revenir bientôt devant les députés
il prévoit l'obligation de signaler à sa
mairie la présence d'un étranger invité
chez soi une loi pas encore en vigueur
mais face à la fronte des cinéastes le
gouvernement n'est pas intimidé dans un
état de droit tous les citoyens sont
tenus de respecter toutes les lois pas
intimidé non plus Eric raout le ministre
de la Ville a écrit à chacun des
réalisateurs signataires pour lui
conseiller un quartier difficile où se
faire héberger pendant quelques semaines
une polémique de plus entre politique et
ciné
de mondes pour lesquels il devient
difficile de trouver le moindre air de
famille